Netflix beat Amazon to the purchase of
Prodigy season 2 but what does that mean
for a possible season three it's not
great welcome to sidere your SciFi TV
and mve
[Music]
channel so we reported a couple of
months ago that Amazon and Netflix were
both in conversations with Paramount
about buying Prodigy SE 2 now we
believed at the time thanks to a couple
of insiders that actually Amazon were
the Front Runners and apparently that
was true Amazon did seem to at least
initially have the most interesting
proposition for Paramount and
Netflix well there is a bigger deal
involved in that that seems to have won
through in the end and to be honest
money but we'll get to that in a second
first of all though the Amazon Deal what
were they actually offering and why did
Paramount then actually turn them down
well a couple of reasons why it was
genely believed by a lot of insiders
that it was going to be going to Amazon
Prime first where well basically Amazon
Prime took Prodigy season one and put it
behind a pay wall as soon as they and
Paramount took it off Paramount plus so
it was believed that that would be
followed up with season 2 and then both
going on Prime that obviously is now not
going to happen now Amazon did put a
cash offer on the table for Prodigy
season 2 that was going to be about 80%
of the cost of production now obviously
power we're not going to be massively
happy about that but Amazon considered
that what they were paying for it to be
a fair price for show that at the end of
the day Paramount didn't even want to
put on Paramount
plus but Amazon were interested and were
seriously talking about commissioning a
season 3 now that was apparently not
going to actually be definite and it was
going to be based on certain performance
criteria so basically when Prodigy
season 2 went on the platform if it
performed at least this well then they
would commission a season 3 but that was
going to actually be contracted so
Amazon would have been tied into that
and Paramount would have had a very good
opportunity to get a season 3 in
production now that would have been
quite a reasonable contract apparently
the numbers weren't ridiculous you know
Amazon weren't expecting Prodigy season
2 to be the most popular TV show on the
service that year or anything like that
apparently it was all very reasonable
and it would have looked like to be
honest very likely we could have got a
season three but Netflix stepped in now
back in 2018 Netflix and parmount did
have a deal for several movies couple of
TV shows Etc and Paramount were
producing things for Netflix Warner
Brothers have recently struck a deal
with Netflix to actually move over
couple of properties from HBO or live or
Max or whatever that's called this week
over to Netflix as well it does look
like Paramount a following suit now what
does this mean for Paramount plus if all
of a sudden Paramount are going back to
what they were doing a couple of years
ago and producing TV shows for Prime you
know perard lower deck Etc and Netflix
internationally Discovery did appear on
Netflix first Netflix and Amazon both
have a really good working relationship
with parent and they have done over a
few years um TNG Enterprise um Voyager
Deep Space 9 were all on Netflix for
years but Paramount over the last few
years have been withdrawing all of that
from Prime and even the Picard season 3
they put it on Paramount plus first and
then Prime only got it the day later so
Paramount has been really trying to put
all its eggs in one basket power Mount
plus but it hasn't gone very well and
debts are mounting we reported here
actually um a couple of months ago again
power's biggest problem isn't actually
that it owes 15 or 16 billion it's that
some of those deals actually end in 2024
and they're going to have to restructure
some of their debt and since they
actually took the debt out interest
rates have gone up quite a lot and
actually their credit rating their
International credit rating was
downgraded slightly 6 months ago so
their debt is going to cost them more so
they're going to end up owing more a lot
of business insiders are actually saying
that the sale of Paramount eventually
isn't just likely it's inevitable and
that actually them pumping all of this
money into Paramount plus is a Fool's
errand so does this mean that Paramount
are going to revert back to its original
plan of producing stuff for other
services well I'm actually being told
that Prodigy was going to Amazon until
about a couple of weeks ago and then it
switched and the Netflix deal took over
Netflix agreed to give them a cash sum
that was a little bit higher than the
production value so actually parmount
will make a little bit of money and
they've also agreed some residuals so
power will actually get more money
depending on how popular Prodigy season
2 and season 1 will be there is no
agreement about a prodigy season 3 but
that is still a possibility but far more
unlikely at the end of the day Amazon
we're willing to put that into the
contract Netflix have declined so why
would Paramount go with this well
apparently this is going to be part of a
much bigger deal that is going to be
announced in the next six to eight
months that parmount are going to be
producing material again for Netflix
supposedly will be a multi-movie and
multi-series deal it could actually even
include some of the stuff that's already
on Paramount plus now moving over to
Netflix in a very similar deal to what
HBO and Warner Brothers have got with
Netflix could this include other Star
Trek properties well I could 100% say
older Trek you know um Star Trek next
Generation maybe and a couple of others
moving over to Netflix again those
properties have always done very well
for Netflix and they would be very happy
to see them there are a couple of new TV
shows that are in development at the
moment Star Trek Academy for example or
possibly even the sex 31 TV movie that
could potentially go onto Netflix I
imagine in both of those scenarios they
would probably go on Paramount plus
first and then move over to Netflix or
maybe move over to Netflix
internationally but again that is very
possible and I'm wondering if this could
be a way of getting Star Trek Legacy
actually funded the problem that
Paramount has with Star Trek at the
moment is that they can't afford to make
all of the track they want to make so
this might be a way for them to mitigate
some of those those costs and risks if
you get Star Trek Legacy paid for by
somebody else then that works out for
the best all around right again this is
something Warner Brothers are doing at
the moment they're trying to produce
material for others Warner Brothers has
really good working relationship with
Apple for example and produce lots of
their movies and lots of their TV series
they're made for Apple by Warner
Brothers these Partnerships across
studios are a common thing they've been
going for a long time time but because
of the streaming Wars a lot of these
production companies and a lot of the
studios were looking internally
producing stuff for themselves those
swords have come to an end everybody
lost so they're going back to form
they're going back to try to mitigate as
many of the risks as possible and that
means power Mount will be looking for
other providers again I actually say no
one won the streaming Wars I actually
think history is going to show that
probably probably Netflix would it I
actually think Netflix a couple of years
ago looking like they were struggling
but now because their platform I think
is just so easy to use you just get what
you pay for it does seem that they're
still the most popular of the streaming
services and to be honest they might
actually come out of this the most
successful in the
end I think we will be seeing streamer
Services merging over the next few years
I actually think the power mount plus
probably will merge with Netflix even
and we probably will just end up with
two or three major streaming platforms
rather than the god I I don't even know
where they are at the moment I actually
think that that's probably going to be
the future and let's hope so because to
be honest there's too damn many at the
moment so guys can in the comments tell
me what you think is this a shame that
we're not going to be getting a prodigy
season 3 or is that actually an okay
sacrifice considering the possibility of
other Star Trek maybe being funded did
by Netflix and that's the only way we're
going to get it so basically if we lose
Prodigy but get Legacy would that be a
fair tradeoff I think most people would
probably agree but get into the comments
and tell me what you think if you are
new to the Channel please like subscribe
hit that Bell notification really helps
us out and you never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to
patreon.com sidre where most of our new
videos appear first and for a small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel you get to see them
without the adverts and you get a free
gift so you can't say fairer than that
also go to
c.co which is our dedicated website
where we have articles related to most
of our stories and you get to see them
with a little bit more detail for you to
digest go check it out as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next
[Music]
time